con más de 24 millones de contagios por
kobe 19 la crisis sanitaria en india ya
desbordada toma varias direcciones esta
semana el país registró más de 4.000
muertos durante varios días la terrible
situación ha provocado la saturación de
los cementerios y crematorios y en
consecuencia hay una creciente
acumulación de cadáveres en las orillas
de los ríos las autoridades siguen
buscando cuerpos lanzados en los
afluentes
cuando alguien fallece sentimos como si
hubiera muerto alguien de nuestra
familia generalmente la muerte de las
personas no te afecta pero en esta
situación vemos morir a mucha gente
debido a la escasez de oxígeno
definitivamente esto nos está pasando
factura de vivir porque ese es el otro
gran problema en índia la falta de
oxígeno ha provocado que el tan anhelado
elemento sea comercializado ilegalmente
para evitar esto las autoridades han
establecido bancos de oxígeno en varias
ciudades en los mercados ilegales
urbanos es necesario pagar un alto
precio para obtener tanques de oxígeno
pero la comunidad aquí los distribuye a
los pacientes de forma gratuita
realmente respeto y aprecio a la
comunidad por esta medida de buen
corazón aunque india es la nación
productora de vacunas contra el coi 19
más grande del mundo sólo 140 y 16
millones de personas de los 1350
millones de habitantes han recibido al
menos una dosis del antígeno según datos
del ministerio de salud ante la
catastrófica segunda ola de la pandemia
en el país este domingo las autoridades
recibieron un segundo envío de dosis de
la vacuna sputnik be de rusia la segunda
ola de la pandemia imparable en india no
deja ver por ahora una luz de esperanza